what's going on everybody it's michael b
jordan here and i'm so excited to
present the latest trailer for my new
film a journal for jordan
[Music]
what's this
it's a journal so you can write to your
son what do i write
tell him who you are
what you believe in
and tell him you love him
[Music]
dear jordan
the moment i met your mother i knew she
was the one he is not exactly my title
[Music]
and after some convincing she fell for
me too
i think you are beautiful
[Music]
i want to see more of your city i'll
take your state your zip code
[Music]
[Music]
we can make this work
[Music]
then you came into our lives
and you were a blessing
how come you barely ever talk about
i think about him all the time
always be courageous in everything you
do
but never be afraid to cry
streams
[Music]
[Music]
i
will
try i pray i don't run out of time
i love you to fix you
i was just thinking that if you need sex
just to help you get through it
then i don't want another woman and i
hope you don't expect me to extend that
same offer because you better keep that
locked up
[Music]
exclusively in movie theaters this
christmas